this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
welcome everybody to the Stanford
seminar on people computers and design
today we have Bill Griswold and today a
lot of us take for granted the fact that
we have a mobile device that has
location-aware services bill was one of
the very first researchers to ever start
exploring this work and so for more than
a decade now Bill's been involved in
ubiquitous computing research looking at
things like the active campus which
provided location-aware services at his
home in UCSD and more recently he's been
working on environmental sensing and
sensor networks bill has also done a lot
of research at the intersection of HCI
and software engineering I think he's
been in many ways a real leading systems
researcher who cares about user
experience issues and so we're very
lucky to have Bill here today it's a
pleasure to be here to talk to you today
and I'm going to be telling you about
our participatory air quality system
citizens so about three years ago I was
at a conference and found this on my
doorstep outside my hotel room and I was
just shocked and I said oh my god you
know what can I do about that you know
sounds this sounds really bad and I went
and did a little additional research and
found out it's it's actually it's a it's
a pretty dire issue so by federal air
quality standards over half of Americans
experience unacceptable air quality
levels in their in their counties every
year so for example it's known that in
the city of Chula Vista near San Diego
there are an additional hundred and
forty cancer cases per million residents
due to air pollution this air pollution
is primarily truck and auto pollution
there are particulates benzene sulfur
sulfur dioxide formaldehyde lots of
things you don't feel like you should be
encountering every as an everyday
experience but it's there in our air you
keep looking a little bit further and
you find out that asthma as an event an
asthma attack is are there
fifty percent higher near highways and
what's what's what's really shocking is
thirty percent of all US schools are
actually near highways by population
health standards about 400 meters and
not surprisingly with demographics like
that there are over a million
respiratory reported respiratory events
annually in children so give you an idea
of the magnitude of this this issue on
top of that there's ongoing research
right now that is teaching us that it's
not just chronic exposures of pollution
that gradually build up your body or
clog up your lungs or give you cancer
that they're actually dangerous to peak
exposure so during a high pollution day
they're increased hospital admissions
for asthma for cardiac events and things
like that and actually increase deaths
so these are actually measurable
consequences of a peak pollution day
okay now that's this isn't even
regulated today in the United States but
eventually it could be as we learn more
about it so how does how does this
breakdown for the federal government
what are they doing about it well in san
diego county it's a big county 4,000
square miles we have over three million
residents and to keep track of the air
quality for these people we have ten
sensors these sensors are not located
predominantly where people live or
commute they're located in places that
it's possible install a big heavy
expensive sensor and keep it secured and
calibrated in things like that it's
meant to capture to regional sort of
Esen arik air quality but doesn't really
tell us that much about exposure that's
sort of a little bit of a mystery today
so if the government can't do it I
believe that we can and by we em
means citizens and computer scientists
because citizens are plentiful and
computers on them cheap computers on
them to monitor air quality and
ultimately exposure so here's my vision
we have this woman Lisa here and she's
here she is in La Jolla near UCSD and
she's thing about going running later
but she's an asthmatic so she could she
could look at the EPA data go pull this
stuff down from the EPA but as you see
there no air quality monitors on this
map so nothing that could really inform
her her decisions about whether today's
a good day to run where she's planning
to run so okay let's drop a little
personal sensor on her and have it
bluetooth to her phone and give her a
display like this well that's great no
it's now she knows something about
what's going on right now but what about
somewhere else in town a little bit
later in the day she's still still a
little bit of a mystery well okay let's
put let's put those boards on more
people on more cell phones in the in the
region and let's we can share that into
the Internet combine it with that EPA
data and then we can compute a a precise
detailed map of air pollution somewhere
else later in the day okay so that's
that's the idea and now we can actually
start to plan our Lisa can start to plan
her run once we have that we can share
that information with public health
practitioners the press and your doctor
if they have any time after their five
minutes a year with you so this is an
idea long and coming actually back in
1998 David Brin the the science fiction
writer wrote this wonderful book called
the transparent Society and he
envisioned this coming age of sensors
and what he noted is that at the time
that the people who had these things
were law enforcement in Walmart but
normal people weren't carrying these
things around and but he asked who's
watching the Watchers and he thought
that everyone should be carrying these
sensors to kind of level the playing
field and give everyone that opportunity
so he sort of i think anticipated this
age of pervasive sensing citizen sensing
in 2001 we got Wikipedia which is a
citizen encyclopedia where we can start
to tell the history the way we want it
to be told the way we believe it not how
World Book believes that our
encyclopedia britannica believes it in
2007 colleague of mine introduced
something called the wireless traffic
report so people could text their
location and a traffic event you could
start to see it on a map and it's a
aggregating of citizen data for for
personal action and then Shannon span
aqui at the same time developed this
little thing called squirrel which is a
carbon monoxide monitor which bluetooth
to your cute little 2007 flip phone and
provided artistic displays on the phone
and also to large public displays she's
a media artist and that was this is
actually the work that inspired citizens
as a computer scientist i extrapolated
what she was doing I said wow that's
really incredible you know I think we
should do this at a really big scale
Shannon now works for the city of San
Francisco on similar issues which is
which is really cool and then later came
a Deborah estrin and the sands group
which developed the idea of
participatory sensing here an example is
this their peer project personalized
estimates of environmental exposure and
impact which use your location in an EPA
data and other ways of estimating to
give you an estimate of your exposure
and your pollution footprint it's all
but the only local sensing is really the
GPS your location or a zip code so the
question is how can we enable
participatory sensing but it's more than
that we want it to be always on
available to us all the time and so
we're getting data from wherever we go
okay wherever we're doing and we wanted
to be real time because we want to be
able to and act on it in the moment and
we want it everywhere always on in real
time so how can we do that this is a
challenging problem the types of sensors
were talking about sensors that are
affordable are they're noisy they have
small errors in them the location that's
reported by the
GPS could be off a little bit and
they're in whatever density we can
deploy these things that it's not
infinitely dense it's going to be sparse
a lot less sparse than the EPA sensors
but still there needs to be some spatial
and temporal interpolation we have a
mobile power problem to have these
things all the time is probably going to
consume a lot of power somewhere in the
system this is these are not temporary
sometimes on campaign based oh well
let's do it for this afternoon we're
talking about all the time we're gonna
need an extensible software architecture
and adaptable software architecture then
adapted local conditions to manage power
and other services and an adaptable way
to the context to provide the right
information for security and privacy
implications and there's questions of
medical efficacy this is what my
colleagues and I are working on I've
been focusing on the HCI component and
this was funded by NSF in a cyber
physical systems project we've been
taking on this constellation of issues
in citizens that's the background the
rest of this talk and tell you about the
citizens system about how we do that
machine learning interpolation spatial
temporal interpolation with noise and we
talk about the power considerations and
then I'll tell you about a user study
we've done with commuters at UCSD that
sheds light on how a system like this
changes the way people think and behave
about air pollution so the the one
component of citizens is this board here
have it right here it doesn't work I
dropped it and it's got a 8-bit
processor some flash and RAM eeprom got
a Bluetooth module for Bluetooth into
the phone it has onboard temperature
humidity and barometric pressure sensors
and it has three electrochemical gas
sensors carbon monoxide no.2 and ozone
we chose those because they're
relatively independent of each other in
terms of their sources instead allows us
to maximize their benefit
and infer what other pollutants are
probably in the area if these are if
these are present this is work by the
hardware's work of Parros Abby who is a
postdoc UCSD now Qualcomm and the app is
primarily due to neiman Nick sod my PhD
student so tell you a little bit about
the app here it's an Android application
it has this at a glance view that
displays the epa's aqi air quality index
it's a simplified version of measures
for air pollution that basically ignores
the source of the pollution and just
maps it into a consequence and then it
gives you a nice color system a number
system than a color system so they can
add a glance say that's good that's bad
and to help the user we have this bar
here that shows you where you are in
that progression and remind you all
right we also have some social sharing
buttons I'll talk about later but if you
you know tap this screen you can drill
down the details you can see what the
offending pollutin is the parts per
million you can get a graph of your
exposure for the day and and then of
course you know tap again and you're
back home again okay so those are the
two primary on body components the phone
connects to the phone connects to a
back-end server which aggregates all
this data where the machine learning is
going to happen it also provides these
personal maps to show you where you've
been that day what exposures you got and
also what your exposures were out
through the day a bit on the phone like
on the phone but in much more detail
there's nothing special about the back
end its of rather you know generic you
know web technology so
let me talk about the machine learning
component a little bit so we have this
spatial and temporal sparseness there's
there's noise in the sensors and in the
GPS and what we want to be able to do is
is learn a an accurate as possible
representation of the pollution at all
points in space and time what we do is
we learn a correlation of of the sensor
values we're gathering and correlate
that also with location and time we then
do what's called latent variable
factorization which basically exposes
real underlying hidden variables if you
will we do a kernel based Gaussian
regression over those latent variables
and then when that's done we translate
it back to the variables that we
understand as an example here is a
temperature data from the Central Valley
temperature is really important for
farming so that they have a lot of
sensors out there and they're actually
if some sensors over here that are
failing and our machine learning system
can actually detect that and fill those
values in and compute a much more
accurate temperature gradient for the
region so how does this look inside
citizens relatively new to the system
we're able to compute these overlays for
a portion of San Diego you can see here
that there's some green good areas here
and then there's some yellow areas that
are around the highway corridor that are
representing sort of moderate air
pollution and knots and not so good
so how do we keep this thing on all the
time the key thing we've been looking at
is reducing the redundancy of the
sensory of the data gathering when
you're gathering readings every six
seconds there's going to be a lot of
readings that are essentially identical
this can come in and so that's going to
would look something like that and we
get a lot of readings like that where do
these come from well if you're in the
same location the pollution is changing
relatively slowly over time unless a
truck drives by or something like that
tends to change gradually throughout the
day a lot of stability we could down
sample for that the other situation is
where you have two people who are
traveling on the same route and so
they're not fixed in space but two
people are sort of locked together in
space as they move together and so we
can also under sample for that so how do
we take advantage of that well we have
mark here who's all by himself someplace
his battery is full he can do full
sampling we throw in Lisa who also has a
full battery and we can interleave
they're sampling and save a good amount
of sampling energy if a battery runs low
we can shift the load back to mark makes
perfect sense right so if you do this in
simulation you can actually save a lot
in in a lot of power and running the
sensor but there's a catch we need to
equate the locations of these people
fairly accurately and that means we need
to communicate either between them or
back to a server to detect the locality
to then down sample the the sampling and
that consumes a lot of energy because it
turns out the communications is a huge
power consumer in these sort of
applications so this doesn't actually
work so we took another shot at
redundancy and looked at the redundancy
of the readings on the phone with
respect to the model that we're
computing on the server you said if the
model is really accurate the server
doesn't need to know about it right so
so what we do is
is we take a portion of the global model
that's local to you we upload it to the
phone and the phone monitors the samples
it's getting relative to the model
within some error epsilon and then if
they get out of band the phones like oh
I have new exciting data here let's
upload it to the server and let it crank
on it and compute a better model where's
the other reason they've readings might
be out of bandits that new model has
been computed but we haven't transmitted
to the phone yet because again we're not
really being aggressive about the
communications so you first update the
model see if that helps if that doesn't
you know then compute a new model and
upload that model so this kind of lazy
approach with this approach we can save
a lot in the communication costs between
28 and eighty percent depending on the
motion profile and the value we compute
for epsilon now how much error were
willing to tolerate in the difference
between the readings and the model
really really really cool idea I thought
I was I was really really impressed by
this result I had nothing to do with it
so all so with that in mind so that's
kind of the system view of it it's like
well how does how does this matter so
what we did is we conduct an exploratory
field study conducted primarily by my
student Liz bales with help from Nicole
quick who was in the School of Medicine
at the time and we want to explore
questions like how do people respond
having a system like citizen so we're
not talking about unhealthy people we're
talking about people who are of typical
typical health and abilities but you
know had this sort of capability on them
we want to look at how it affected their
awareness and how it affected their
behavior and how did it affect their
communities how did how was that
relationship with their friends and
their community how is that altered or
shifted so to get this we looked we
recruited commuters at UCSD these are
people who are producing air pollution
to a certain degree at least the ones
who are driving cars or taking the bus
and also our consumers of it because
they're on the roads at times where
there's a lot of traffic so we gave we
recruited 16 healthy adults we
had them carry the the board and a
dedicated phone for a month so we didn't
have them use their own phone we just
gave them one of ours Kari for one month
and we asked these can we expect these
commuters two be commuting fairly far
you know more than 20 minute commute
each way so sizable commutes we also
asked the be regular uses or Facebook
because we have this Facebook
communication capability to look at the
social networking aspects of it okay
their demographics eight males eight
females ages 22 56 average age of 38 so
not a young group they had actually
rather long commutes average of thirty
six miles round trip and a wide variety
of backgrounds and no professors so its
people typical backgrounds there's even
a painter you know people who big paint
being buildings papers things like that
they also had a wide variety of
commuting styles and this was
intentional our part this was a meant to
be an exploratory study it's like what
happens what do people do we thought
that the varying backgrounds of people
might influence the way they think about
and react to and reason about air
pollution so we had people who cycle
walk bus a car train just go in a lot of
lot of variation there okay this is just
a sampling of the fur of eight of the
subjects for these subjects we had a pre
study mid study and end of study
questionnaire and we had an open-ended
interview at the end of the study to
discuss with them of course we had all
their citizens data we gave them the the
phone and the board with those
capabilities we talked about earlier in
addition the Facebook capability so that
if when they post a facebook it would
take the data that's on the server
actually and provide a link to that map
that I showed you earlier a somewhat
privatized version of that map so that
their friends could see where they've
been for the last several hours and what
the pollution profile was and things
like
that we had tried a purely textual
communication on Facebook but people
couldn't get a good sense of the
location and of course I didn't give a
sense of their whole day so they're so
this map was really no critical to the
communication and we also made available
on the phone this chart to remind them
what these different levels of exposure
meant in terms of their health 0 to 50
being good and all the way up through
three hundred and above which is
extremely hazardous ok that's the map I
talked about earlier so so here's an
example of one commuters exposure
they're actually biking through here
from work to home see it's really good
on the left it peaks as they're crossing
the highway they reach another peek over
here because there's another highway
right over here that you can't see and
then it drops down as they progress to
their home so we started to analyze
their data we first looked at the
initial stages of discovery and growing
awareness of the air pollution around
them many of the users referred to
citizens as a sixpence and when I saw
that I told my student Liz that's a
great you know starting title for our
paper she said sorry bill everyone's
already used it about a half dozen times
it's taken I said well what about 7th
sense or an 8th sense we got to do
something here she said no sorry that
was kind of disappointing but people did
talk about in that and what it really
speaks to is this we've made the
invisible visible to them something that
they couldn't see before that they could
see now and that's what they really
meant by this sixth sense idea so for
example participant for talked about I'm
pleasantly surprised that the quality of
air around my work in home environment
is generally high another said it never
occurred to me how bad the air is as
cars drive by while I'm waiting for the
bus and p6 said I've become more aware
of how things like freeways power plants
etc affect the surrounding area I always
just thought of the atmosphere is being
evenly mixed but it is not and this this
this was a recurrent theme you know
mentioned here as well
that the users general misconception was
that the air pollution was relatively
evenly distributed and if you look at
the EPA maps that they provide on a
daily basis that are updated hourly
that's what they look like but that's
not actually what people are living in
and experiencing an hour our system
shows that show that shows that shows
that difference and so here now that our
users understood that the pollution
they're experiencing was different in
different places and times and we also
began to see some really interesting
sense making activities 13 out of 16 of
our participants sought out possible
causes for the air pollution that they
were seeing so for example p9 said I
always see a spike in the in the air
quality values when i arrived at UCSD I
think it's when I walk through an area
where several of the city buses are
stopped and running we've had that
second mention of the bus stop and it's
going to come up a couple more times and
what we found for these participants
that the real-time nature of the
readings was crucial that is that they
would see something a pollution possible
solution source or they'd be glancing at
their phone and it would merely say his
a twit what's going on here and they
would whatever piece was missing they
look for it so if they saw pollution
source they get out their phone if they
had their phone they'd start looking
around for a pollution source so the
real-time aspects were really important
another thing that was really important
was the glanceable design of the display
that we just were just telling them by
color and by number good not so good
pretty bad really awful they didn't have
to worry about the pollution source or
what parts per million went or anything
like that so it freed them up
cognitively to look around and think
about what's going on in their
environment rather than doing math and
their heads so for example p16 said for
the most part I looked at it was in the
green so it wasn't too bad p11 said
walking up to the Triton the pollutants
were at 250 ish for quite a few days a
few days what's over there so we hear
the the use of green and the these
numbers they've totally abstracted away
what the pollutant is and the value is
they just talk about these things
naturally as sort of being native
obviously this this sort of reasoning
led to people to question their
assumptions and ultimately revise their
mental models about what pollution would
likely look like it looked like in their
environment you know when they weren't
constantly glancing at the phone and
ultimately it became a foundation for
behavior change so uh we actually had
feared that when people would see this
information that they become despondent
oh my god you know look at this you know
terrible pollution you know I'm dying
and you know truth be told San Diego has
relatively clean air and these are
middle-class people who live in
relatively you know air clean
neighborhoods so that really wasn't to
be a concern but was really interesting
is that people took this information and
they started using their inferences to
modify their behavior they started
avoiding avoiding busy streets when
walking they instead of walking down the
main thoroughfare they go one street
over they would back up from the from
the street at the bus stop and back up
20 yards because the pollution was a lot
lower there they would the people who
commuted on the train would stand back
from the engine they'd stand more
towards the back of the train or
something like that one implementers in
their workplace and p10 said something
like oh well so this is actually
interesting this is again a workplace
issue this was a student who worked in
electrical engineering lab where they
were doing soldering and what the people
are doing the soldering now moved their
soldering out outdoors into the hallway
so that they would vent to the outdoors
instead of collect collect indoors and a
p6 said I'm more conscious of leaving my
car idling in keeping the windows closed
on the freeway again one is the idling
may be enough affecting them so directly
as something they're doing for everybody
but another thing that people have
noticed is that they roll their windows
down the car that the pollution exposure
seemed to be higher
the change in awareness also led to add
a tube changes so p8 said I try to keep
abreast of environmental issues and this
has definitely opened my eyes the
potential to bring awareness to the
public is always key this is as I
reference back to this making the
invisible visible again is that once we
can make this invisible thing tangible
people respond to in a completely
different way and could actually change
the way people think another interesting
thing we observed was that the
importance of that these were personal
mobile sensors that they carried in
their bodies that they weren't installed
static sensor fixed sensors in the
environment and in particular these
types of sensors would normally be
installed in public places but not in
the home and maybe not in the workplace
so p6 said it seems like my gas stove
kicks out carbon monoxide and it isn't
vented that concerns me another talked
about the use of incense and this is the
this is the soldering a fellow again
anywhere where you're working with
electrical equipment or chemicals like
the air quality seems fine but the
readings say otherwise and so we can see
that the ability to carry this into your
place and see it as your exposure rather
than computing a pollution in the
environment which is interesting but not
connected to you is kind of a different
this is a different experience in
different quality it's actually
different data so the other thing we
noticed is that there's a hyperlocal
quality to this information so the
people who commuted uh in carpool zoran
trains reported things like this I share
the readings on the train and elsewhere
and they are usually interested they
seem like me surprised at the difference
in your freeways and and in what we
found is that that that there is this
conversation making that happen around
the device and the readings in part
because they're visible but in part
because it was my exposures your
exposure if we're in the same car the
same train and to us it felt like this
is like the way people talk about the
weather
or sports or you know other things that
are happening in our daily lives these
are things that people could share and
talk about freely because it was you
know in their environment part of their
daily lives the other interesting thing
is that the Facebook interactions were
often in discussions were often with
people who lived close to you and
traveled similar routes to you and in
fact they the Facebook conversations
were often just conversation starters
for face-to-face conversations so p14
said the Facebook post to me were
jumping off point when I would see
someone in real life they would bring it
up so we see this is bringing back to
the faith this face-to-face element and
referring back to was Scott mentioned
earlier my act of campus work my act of
campus work I was I was trying to change
the dynamics I saw with mobile phones
where everyone is talking to a phone and
not paying attention what they're doing
or their texting and bumping into things
I want an act of campus to cause you to
look up and say oh there I have a friend
nearby well there's this interesting
talk oh there's that restaurant that I
was looking for that's what I wanted to
happen with active campus and completely
accidentally we discovered this is what
citizens does that that because it's
it's happening right here right now in
my personal environment others around me
are interested in and this is
information about my in Vienna media
environment so it causes me to look up
look for what's happening around me and
then to talk to people who are around me
and those people are interested in the
data as well so we start to see maybe I
hope a new class of applications that
mobile applications that connect people
to their environments rather than
separate them and take them out of those
environments another interesting
observation was that we had many people
traveling on the same commute routes but
actually having rather different
exposures we had people riding on bikes
who had these you know rather high
pollution readings and the people in
cars who didn't and it's because of the
rolled up windows and the cabin air
filters that modern cars have now
changes you know what was experienced
inside the car if you have the windows
rolled up
and we also the same thing that the
people riding the bus are experiencing
these buses pulling in and pulling out
constantly you know especially when they
hit the gas it's just you know this big
gas cloud and they're the they're taking
the brunt of it even though they're
doing something to reduce the pollution
in the area by riding the buses of
driving a car the biker is reducing the
air pollution but is the greater
recipient of the air pollution so
tragically those who are doing the most
to clean the air are paying a price for
that and there's kind of a disparities
quality this data as well is that the
people who ride buses are generally less
wealthy than the people who are driving
in Alexis to work the people who are
biking may not have a car and may not
have that choice available to them so
there's a steaming ubiquitous computing
about who pays for the technology and
who benefits and we often see in a
symmetry there and we're seeing that
again here in this in this hyper local
context and it may point to barriers and
actually further cleaning up the air
because a lot of the people with the
political power is like air pollution
what air pollution that's the poor
bikers and bus riders who continue to
pay the price what it meant for us
though is that it highlights the
potential of participatory systems like
citizens to expose these disparities and
cause a discussion about them so
although citizens didn't directly convey
this data we didn't allow we didn't
display other people's data you know for
each other to see we saw this in the
thing some users discovered it anyway
because some days they biked some days
they drive some stand at the bus stop
you know some stand back from the bus
they experiment they discover this for
themselves but in redesigning this
system or in extending the design system
which in fact we've already done in in
more recent studies we want to display
other people's data and have people
question you know why are they seeing
different data than other people on the
road so to summarize weeks weeks through
this making the invisible visible we've
exposed numerous misconceptions that
people had about air pollution
sometimes they thought they had that air
pollution it was good other times it was
the other way around was this general
notion of uniformity whether it's in
space and time and even individual I
must have the same pollution as that
pollution not so we also expose this
this interesting data that indoor air
pollution is kind of a problem i mean
this EPA knows this scientists know this
but these people got to see this
firsthand and and another misconception
was dispelled we also saw that real time
at a glance displays enabled a important
sense making and actually let people
take action even if in a small way to
take control of their health in there
air pollution exposure they're able to
identify sources change their behaviors
and talk to other people around them
about it and start a discussion that
could ultimately lead to some sort of
political change and finally this this
thing I just talked about of this is
data that that connect the connects
people to the world around them and to
the people around them and the people
around them back to them was a really
interesting idea and to me suggests a
new class of ubicomp systems or way of
thinking about design of ubicomp systems
to maintain and recreate that engagement
rather than destroy it as we've done so
far so to conclude I like to observe
that by capturing personal air quality
in real time citizens can give give
people a measure of control over their
lives by making the invisible visible
people can change their awareness their
attitudes and ultimately their their
behavior more broadly we see the
participatory sensing can address
problems that are beyond the recent
reach of institutions whether it's
personally or hopefully at some point at
the political level several
contributions that I've highlighted
today a particular hardware software
system design with our board the phone
in the backend server the machine
learning components showed how we can
use machine learning to infer air
quality everywhere for everyone so
that's not just
while carrying the boards but anyone
with a mobile phone or access to a web
browser can now see what the air
pollution is likely like where they are
or where their friends are we talked a
bit about power management to prolong
battery life to allow an always-on
real-time system and an interaction
design that supports sense making these
appropriating this EPA aqi system was
really effective at creating at a glance
display so the people could do sense
making rather than math in their heads
and then finally out of that we see that
saw these new patterns of sense making
behavior change attitudinal change and
sharing so any questions smokers I think
you got to be yeah I think you might
have the thing changes yea I'm guessing
the answer is no because I think it
would have shown up in the paper I'd
have to ask liz and we got a lot of
introduced but i think i think the
answer is no it was confused or was
definitely into the person who burned
incense you know I think as possible
they're smokers that weren't so open to
talking about it yeah this isn't San
Francisco yeah so it along the same
lines between veteran traditional us
sensing systems of besides coming up
with good modeling and data aggregation
to two of the early hard cards are one
encouraging communication and the other
one is fixture in terms of guaranteeing
leading the proper situation of sensor
with its environment these various
influences double switch silencing
community in your case I just need half
of your little boxes are in purses so
much are they sensing revlon she sado
instead of been crossed off with zo
right so me Dave they have little straps
on the back velcro straps and when we we
talked to our users said you know please
mount this on the outside you know they
put it out of the tattoo
purse or to their backpacks or something
like that it might have ended up in the
purse it is and even when you're doing
that there's some interesting
consequences so for example when you're
in a car with the windows rolled up
you're getting a measure of exposure
inside the cabin of the car it's not
telling you what the pollution is
outside the car and so our maps are in
some sense exposure maps they're not a
pollution in the air maps they're
different than their different than the
EPA's maps possible we had we haven't
done it you could think of it it's it's
a it's a source of error if you will but
you could use a variety of things there
are a lot of ubicomp techniques for
detecting oh I'm traveling at the speed
or indoor/outdoor there's light like
characteristic sound characteristics you
know lack of movement for a long periods
of time you could use google knows a lot
about the built infrastructure now there
are lots of things that can be done it
still be you know obviously you know
subject to error but at least we could
start labeling the data with
indoor/outdoor and then you could
actually flip a switch and say show me
endure show me or show me exposure show
me estimated pollution levels but we
don't have that right now we just have
these exposure maps and if you look at
that closely at that map I showed you
earlier you see UCSD looks greener than
the roads around it and part of that is
that people spend most of their time
indoors at UCSD and so we're actually
again looking at exposure not a little
the light pollution levels so it's but
it's an important part of the machine
learning to actually be able able our
data with that with this additional
context yeah you find that any of the
forgivable bikers commune outside change
their actual house to avoid I pro
billiard follow the areas or anything
that well we heard from people who were
Walker's that they would go one road
over and walk those are probably people
who lived in up these um you know
Manhattan style roads where they can
make adjustments a lot of the commute
pass into UCSD you really don't have a
lot of choices it's more of a
hub-and-spoke tiles type of system but
you know the the data says no but they
certainly would have liked to
thank the implications for behavior
change are really fascinating and I'm
wondering if it is known or if you know
anything about sort of margin of
consequence so how big a difference in
air quality actually should I care about
okay it's cute but whoa if a difference
of five is just noise a difference of 50
mm maybe I want to do something at
wonder if you have any kind of index of
that sort right we did not train our
users or educate our users about this
and in fact not that much is known so
that there's a difference between for
example chronic exposure which is sort
of a build up over decades and as
something for me to worry about having
grown up in New Jersey and versus peak
exposures which sensitive populations
are very sensitive to and lead to
hospital admissions and so we did not
educate people and we just used the AQI
system but it was something to note that
we appropriately aqi system and but
didn't call it a Qi we call it Meek we
my instantaneous aqi a Qi is really an
hourly average measure of pollution in
an area where as what we're collecting
is instantaneous is much more spiky and
could probably you know could they
likely come out to the averages that the
EPA estimates except that it's really
about where people spend their time so
if they're spend a lot of time in the
highways it's going to be much higher
than the EPA would estimate if they
spend their to all our time indoors it
could actually be much lower and so we
actually call it used to call a Qi now
we call it this am I aqi whether it's
more valuable to avoid short but wild
spikes versus you know any of that kind
of four different people is going to be
different so i have a new research
project called delphi which is looking
at the data mining aspect of this since
it essentially a database project we're
going to be merging medical records
personal health data like weigh-ins
genomic data environmental data so we
can't start to say for you peak exposure
bad for you chronic exposure bad and try
to unravel all that but it's going to be
that's going to be a
a super big data question that you know
we won't have our head around probably
for another decade or so only saw one of
the original foam you set out which was
that the EPA machines were huge and
really expensive they seemed really
cheap and you could mount them on cell
phone towers all around city how hard
even doable that kind of thing would be
to push on right so there are multiple
aspects to this so the fixturing
fixturing question was mentioned earlier
and the EPA devices are sort of well
fixture to do high quality sampling if
not in the right place getting them in
the right place compromises a lot of
that also our sensors are relatively low
quality you know the voltages in the
board aren't precise all the time
because it's battery-powered they're
cheap they need to be calibrated every
six months I'm sure the EPA sensors are
calibrated more often than that just
because they want to get it right but
certainly some people some cities are
doing this now I know in New York City
is doing fine grain sampling an
interesting thing though is is that the
reason that EPA sampling happens now is
to regulate highway funding too much
pollution no highway funding so the air
quality districts that do the monitoring
do not have a lot of incentive to do
high quality high density monitoring
they would prefer the average the
numbers be really average in kind of low
so it really this is where it comes back
to sort of Citizen Action and I think
some cities are you know as opposed to
counties are kind of taking control of
this probably New York City doesn't get
a lot of highway data I mean sorry
highway funding so so there's there some
tensions here but it's certainly
possible and you could put these dip you
could fix these devices and put solar
panels on them you could install them in
mail trucks or cabs you can have
sensitive populations carry them because
I think asthmatics elderly and
high-performing athletes would all be
interested in this data there a lot of
interesting scenarios we don't know it's
going to play out another thing we don't
know is that it really really looking at
ecology of devices and sensors because
I'm also going to be wearing a go where
that does my heart rate stuff and
something for you know diet and you know
wait and all these sort of things
they're gonna have a lot of devices a
lot of them
power what is going to be the hub that
all that data coaster is going to be my
cell phone or something else I'm going
to have two data plans it's kind of
these are all open questions yeah what
do you mean building a doors question
what do you see as real opportunities
for a changing either human behavior or
policy like if I can't fight by another
route is it worth collecting the data or
for the biker so you cross the highway
you tell them put on a face mask and
then at the policy level I'm sure you
thought about something along the lines
of automatically now my congressperson
when I cross onto the safety highway
yeah I mean it's you know you don't know
how these things on hold right because
you don't know where the real pain
points are and where the real power
points are we're going to start looking
at a community south of San Diego called
San Ysidro which is right on the border
with Tijuana it's in the United States
right at the border there two highways
to converge there and there's traffic
backed up on both sides trying to get
the border and you have all these idling
trucks a lot of trucks of all most of
the trucks are actually one stop over if
you a couple mile down the road but
there's just it's really awful and the
San Ysidro just had this new school
built for them that is right in the
heart of this pollution spot it's one of
these schools that's right next to a
highway and it's going to be interesting
to see what this community can do
they've already recruited San Diego
State University our sister University
to do air quality sampling for them and
try to change the policies at the border
to reduce the idling vehicles and all of
that it's just not clear you know what
you know there's a federal issue isn'ta
locally how is it going to it's it's
really hard to say and I think it's
going to be very interesting interesting
to see you know I've talked to a couple
of EPA people at meetings like this but
I haven't gone to my local air quality
district inside ah can we talk that's
sort of now that we have the fully run
system you know we're able to do that
and will be interesting to see how that
side of the discussion unfolds yeah can
you talk more the personal you set up a
policy issues that for DP I mean five
years as a few have some sense electives
and you're biking usually and it tells
you it's a good play DS and you gotta
stop doing it right which is the
opposite of what you would want right so
I'm wondering what are the little notice
if he can make this work the right
direction yeah yeah I mean it's a really
reminds me the other half of Scott's
question which is there there could be
the reaction like I'm not taking the bus
anymore it'll be worth it for me to buy
a car with a good cabin air filter and
like oh no and but i think you know we
have to look really hard at this you
can't you suppress the data right
because it's sort of not what we wanted
to see uh you know I it's it I don't
know right but I just think that you
know for myself and I still bike and I
bike on one of those polluted roads that
get the little you know hi hi for bikers
low for drivers things I'm I'm insisting
on doing and I was like dang it you're
not going to stop me but um I just don't
know what we could do to nudge people in
the right direction a good sort of
question is is there can we shame people
can we inspire them you know I'm not a
actually it's here you see a see there's
this a persuasive health thing that's
going on with BJ Fogg right so we all
need to go down to talk to him and say
how can we persuade people to do the
right thing and not you know so it's
just I have to give you a change of you
could just have more triggers to make it
easier to do the sort of behavior like
if you are really maps it gives you a
low pollution browser oh yeah right so
there are possibilities because we have
the big picture you could start
suggesting you know alternative routes
that's that's a good point
yeah yeah certainly things like that
yeah and also the time of day matters
for people in communities near the one
run over things sure yeah that would be
and we assume the people would be would
be doing that because some well some
people did yeah so it's very clear that
users can view their our environment and
you said it there while them and to kind
of pick out other sources may be there
is any way reduced measure with her own
attack on the environment like in this
case ye may be less comprehend I'm sorry
yeah that's helping and driving but is
there a way i see that they're driving
is actually contributing to the
detriment of others yeah so that's not
the weekend collect we clicked our the
data we collect is sort of aggregate
pollution but the pure project has an
element of this which is ok I'm July
driving a Toyota Corolla in 1989 you
know this is what its catalytic
converter operates like this is what
you're driving a little bit more data
you know plug into the data port under
the dash you could say well how often
does this guy slam on the gas and slam
on the brakes which pollutes a lot more
than driving gently so those things are
certainly certainly possible and and
there's been a lot of research on that
so I mean like the pure project there's
also a project at the University of
Washington and it was Intel an Intel
Labs when it was still open they're I
forget the name of the project but they
they had they did that that kind of a
thing and it was meant to inspire people
and persuade them to do to the right
thing that would basically show they
showed a tree with grow leaves if you
were doing I think Senate tree would
wilt a little bit if you didn't do the
right things that is a nice nice clever
idea yeah if I bicycle by your hybrid
car which is lower visions it could
automatically send the thank you
send a nastygram to the fellow or gasps
Yugi behind it that'll be my chammak
open how many Nissan Leafs is to take to
offset arm yeah princess so there's bits
of mentioned in terms of this sort of
the actors involved in the social level
of individuals and Impala and public
policy what about the notion of tracking
down the sources of these things
particularly maybe not so much CEO
really primary source is this
distributed individually owned heartily
infrastructure but save the volatile
hydrocarbons in particular and you know
dioxin derivatives those are industrial
processes what you see is a possibility
of say seeding communities that have to
glue down wind in refinery clones with
periodic emergencies we see it up in
richmond and 35 years i mean this is
this is all our data so that their
action can can be well-founded and very
pointed yeah this is already happening
so this is what happened in San Isidro
where they recruited the people they
have exposure scientists use you they
have these very expensive $50,000 boxes
that can mention capture what are called
ultra fine particulates very expensive
to do so ultra fine are these
particulates that are emitted from
natural gas combustion and things like
that because they're the natural gas
buses bad news ultra fine particulates
are worse than regular particulates
because they directly enter your
bloodstream so now you have little
particulates in your blood rather than
sticking in your lungs where you could
eventually cough them out and they were
essentially unregulated at this point
and it's kind of sad but this is that
this is sort of you know I think core of
this sort of citizen science you know
participatory sensing moving and it's
sort of this campaign based style would
you go out and collect a bunch of data
create visualizations of it and then you
shove it under people's noses and say
look at what you're doing to us and it's
it's very it's very exciting work as the
the prices are dropping exponentially
fast they're the battery technologies
the power is lower and lower and so
these things are shrinking fast you can
now make a particulate sensor that
normal particulates 2.5 it's about as
big as this and as a little fan that
sucks air through a little filter and
then you measure I think it's
reflectance off of the filter the
reflectance reduces as the pollution
builds up and and you know it's a few
grand costs money but it's Goffe is
going to keep dropping and eventually we
can even put a particulate sensor on
this so it's a really exciting time and
it's a lot of this is being fed by the
maker movement as well so Scott just
sent me a link there's a maker event
tomorrow is it up in San Francisco
people are building stuff like this all
the time because you all you need is you
know an Arduino BTW and some
electrochemical sensors and okay
calibrations hard but it's people are
doing cool stuff it's I mean it's really
just you know we're all all the cool
kids are going to be doing it soon no it
was having to trade me know so here's my
hypothesis there's a bus waiting station
on the other side of the of this mall
where the buses wait before they pull
out to the place where the the the bus
riders waiting bus riders get gassed
they probably spend a lot of time idling
there when they start up they and so
that pollution probably comes out the
back floats up to the side of this
enormous facade this is Otis Triton is
this you know guy standing like this
with water spouting out of them right
right in front of this large facade for
the student center and probably the
pollution just pushes up there and just
sits there because there's no place
where to go you know I think co is
heavier right so it's just kind of kind
of settle there and then it needs you
need a breeze or something to kind of
get it to dissipate but it's just a
guess I have no idea certainly the ones
in front of the bus stop or much much
it's much easier to tell what's going on
there
thanks me thank you
you